hey get that Meehan thing we recently
did a video or we were doing like oh
what's in my bag type of thing to see
like who knows each other better but
this time we're gonna do that here at
Universal Orlando Resort cue the fanny
packs let's let the cut cut confident
you're directing this video how did you
even get here
I took a private jet all the way here
let's go let's shot it's gotta be
authentic to curly you know channeling
curly right now if I work really well
what I want all the shops are super cute
super love vintage e things and like
retro looking things I love this tank
but this little cutie sweater I want to
get like a picture frame because like I
really love curly I think like this trip
is gonna be like memorable so I want to
get this so he can be like picture
picture picture memories Oh crystals
these are good for healing and
protection to keep the haters away you
didn't I'm saying how to keep the hate
is a way think he definitely needs an
award of some sort world's greatest
grandpa because he dresses like a
grandpa a lot I think we're on brand
we're doing good I think we're good
curly are you ready I'm ready
so this is what I got you oh you got me
this I love
good slash it's like a finger moment
together and it was like my first time
here like in Orlando and also like the
Universal Orlando Resort you know I get
emotional for things like this when I
need this right now
Oh clearly yours this is look this is
your brand you got me a golf ball a good
old regular memorabilia type thing in
your house you know I don't play golf
never forget got you an award for
something very special
don't make me cry again moya world's
greatest grandpa
that's so name thank you
oh my gosh we had so much fun here at
Universal Orlando Resort I can't believe
that we got to share this experience in
the moment with each other here let's go
change take a shoot me buddy okay really
yeah it's something to remember
Universal by
[Music]